it's a great pleasure to be joined Today
by George mombio who is a best-selling
author Guardian columnist environmental
activist and whose latest book is
Regenesis feeding the world without
devouring the planet it's really great
to have you on and you know this is a
conversation that could start in any
number of points but but maybe let's
start it this way I think many of us now
realize intuitively that planning on
indefinite growth on a on a planet of
limited resources mathematically makes
little sense there's something that we
recognize there intuitively however
there are various perspectives as to
what the sort of real big issue is
whether it is transportation emissions
fossil fuels eating meat whatever the
case may be what's the best way to frame
the problem to be solved and what is the
most sensible approach to solving that
problem
so so the the problem is the Gathering
collapse of Earth Systems it's not a
climate problem it's not a soil problem
it's not a forest problem it's not a
fish problem it's not a transport
problem it's it's not an anything else
problem it's an everything problem it's
all Earth Systems together are suffering
massive strain as a result of human
activity
and these are our life support systems
these are what sustain this remarkable
beautiful diverse abundant planet on
which we are so lucky to live
and all these Earth Systems are complex
systems
which means it means a very specific
thing they're self-organizing and
they're self-stabilizing within a range
of stress but you push them beyond that
range and the self-organizing properties
become self-amplifying
and they then amplify shocks passing
across the network until the point when
they hit their critical threshold
and collapse into a different
equilibrium State can you give that a
couple of examples of that because it
may in the abstract it may not be
obvious what that means
well a classic example was the great
Dust Bowl which you in in North America
will be well familiar with in fact it's
one of many dust bowls that have
happened over history but it's the one
that everyone knows about
and soil is a complex system it's a
fascinating extraordinary ecosystem from
which we get 99 of our calories
but if you hit it and hit it and hit it
repeatedly with bad plowing with other
bad decisions in agriculture then you
degrade it and degrade it and you might
not notice very much to begin with
you'll notice perhaps a slight drop off
in crop yield a few other issues taking
place but it's still there still seems
to be functioning okay but what's
happened is that unbeknown to you it has
lost its resilience and then an external
shock comes along like a major drought
and instead of damping down that shock
and regulating itself as a healthy
system does this degraded system
amplifies that shot and suddenly
collapses and the rate of erosion of
soil erosion when when it's highly
degraded and hit by a major drought can
rise 6 000 fold more or less overnight
it just falls off a cliff and then the
soil which stays on the land because
it's a biological structure like a coral
reef it's built by the little creatures
that live in it
um because that biological function has
collapsed the structure completely
collapses and then it can literally blow
away it can just blow away in the wind
or wash away with the rain and suddenly
there's no soil on the land and that
that's what happened in the great Dust
Bowl many other dust bowls but it's what
happens in different ways to every kind
of complex system another one which very
nearly collapsed was the financial
system in 2008 and again very similar
reasons it it behaves in an almost
identical fashion bizarrely and it's
self-organizing without human agency
obviously there's human agency involved
but the human agency doesn't control the
structural Dynamics within that system
and it came within a whisker of collapse
and it was only a bailout globally
amounting to trillions of dollars that
prevented that complete collapse into a
new equilibrium state which would have
been very hard indeed to come come back
from
speaking of of equilibrium States I'm
curious your thoughts to pick one area
that you've written about and that is a
big subject of discussion you know when
we talk about for example our food
system there are a number of different
perspectives about what particular
aspect of it is problematic and sort of
individual as well as collective
decisions that can and arguably should
be made one perspective is well it's
really about which foods are being eaten
and for example if we went off
completely of animal Agriculture and
replace protein with you know this is
not groundbreaking stuff here right
we're talking about soy and almond and
all these different things then we
things we would just be much better off
and then the counter to that has been
well you know
almond and avocado extraordinarily water
intensive they're transporting bees to
the west coast of the U.S half the bees
die so by number of organisms you're
doing damage in a different way what
about the idea of a regenerative type of
Agriculture Which is less about do we
include animal products or not but using
land in a different way and there's some
interesting pilot projects of this being
done in the United States and the
counter to that becomes well that's
really lovely for I forget the guy's
name in Virginia who's doing it but
that's not that useful if you're then
transporting that food across the
country or it would have so it becomes
really difficult for the quote average
person to really know what should I do
and what should we do as a society how
do we parse some of these discussions
yeah no well these are all the right
questions the first thing is that the
term regenerative has become a bit like
the term sustainable it's slapped in
front of anything you happen already to
be doing so regenerative ranching
formerly known as ranching all right and
um it's and it's I mean it hasn't been
used for very long but it's already
completely lost its meaning and everyone
says oh well yes of course what I'm
doing is regenerative and you say Okay
regenerative of what what are you
regenerating here
so in in some parts of the US and and
certainly where I live in the United
Kingdom if it's to be ecologically
regenerative one of the absolute
Baseline
um uh conditions for that is that trees
can return to a formerly forested land
if there were once trees on your land
and the trees are not coming back that
is not an ecologically regenerative
system that's a really really basic
measure of whether it's ecologically
regenerative or not and of course
agricultural systems you know they don't
let trees come back spontaneously
because you know either you're plowing
the land or you're grazing animals which
selectively browse out tree seedlings
because they're very tasty and
nutritious so so that's not going to
happen so ecologically it doesn't even
meet the most basic the crudest measure
of what regenerative means
in terms of keeping soil on the land
there's no doubt that some systems are
better at doing that than others but
against it you must weigh how much are
they producing so so what you've got to
measure against this idea of how well
it's protecting the soil is is also how
much it's producing so if you've got a
very extensive system occupying a huge
amount of land not doing very much
damage to the soil but not producing
very much either that can be just as
damaging in all sorts of other ways as a
very intensive system which is doing
more damage to the soil but producing
lots of food and the reason for that is
the massive ecological opportunity costs
and carbon opportunity costs of
extensive farming what that means is
that every hectare or every acre of land
that you're using could have been
supporting a wild ecosystem if you
weren't using it it could have been
supporting a forest or a natural
grassland or a Savannah or Wetland all
of which are crucial ecosystems and the
great majority of the world species
depend on wild ecosystems for their
survival so a lot of what's called
regenerative is just actually extensive
it's low yield farming occupying a lot
of land and that's agricultural sprawl
and just like urban sprawl agricultural
sprawl is a very bad thing we should be
leaving as much land as we possibly can
for nature so the Holy Grail what we
really need to look for
is farming which has high yield and low
impact and that's a really hard thing to
achieve a few farmers are managing to do
that and and we should celebrate that
and find ways of replicating what
they're doing but we shouldn't be
celebrating either high yield and high
impact or low yield and low impact let
alone in some cases particularly
ranching low yield and high impact
that's a very worst kind of system and
unfortunately the great majority of
cattle and sheep ranching tick sap box
low yield high impact they kill the
large Predators they exclude the trees
they exclude the wild herbivores it's an
ecological disaster
so Joel Saladin at polyface farms was
was the guy I was thinking of earlier
and so there are these different ideas
that include uh micro bike microbial
proteins insect protein a shift to
Perennial crops vertical farming uh
Slash indoor farming slash Urban farming
which are sort of overlapping ideas do
any of those get this idea of high yield
and low impact some do some don't some
are much more successful than others and
you know there's a lot of nonsense in
this field you have to really carefully
pass you know what where's the nonsense
where's where's a good common sense
um the one that um hits the button most
effectively is precision fermentation
growing food from microbes so for 12 000
years we've been using multicellular
organisms animals and plants to produce
our food and we've been breeding them
and breeding them and pushing them to
their very limits and Beyond you know if
you go into an intensive chicken farm or
hog farm you'll see animals push beyond
their their limits but we've scarcely
begun with single-celled organisms and
these are super productive and use far
less in terms of land in terms of water
in terms of fertilizer and other
environmental resources you can produce
according to one set of estimates I did
all the world's protein on an area of
land the size of greater London our
capital city in the UK all the world's
protein and that then would enable you
to release huge tracts of land for
ecological restoration that's genuine
regeneration bringing back ecosystems
that we've destroyed what sort of food
item would it be that one is consuming
in that in that estimate so um what it
produces is a high protein flour about
60 protein that you can turn into almost
anything so um I had it in its raw State
I was the first person in the world
outside the laboratory staff to eat a
pancake made of of microbial flour
um did it taste like chicken
surprisingly as they said
actually bizarrely it tasted like a
pancake okay
it was a small flip for men and um the
um and but you know that was just simply
taking the the flower yeah made from the
the dead bodies of these bacteria
um turning it out mixing it with a bit
of wheat flour because the protein
content was too high otherwise you would
have made an omelette
um um and then a bit of water and bang
you you've got a pancake but then
because these proteins are much closer
to animal proteins and plant proteins
are you can produce animal like products
much more easily much more effectively
far less processing
um tastier cheaper a whole lot but you
can do all sorts of other things as well
and just like the Agricultural
Revolution produced a whole load of
products that people couldn't even
imagine I mean when the first people
caught a wild cow they weren't thinking
a Camembert right
um so the the microbial Revolution will
produce Endless Possibilities that we
can't even picture at this time all
sorts of new tastes and textures and and
flavors the last thing I want to ask you
about zooms out a little bit you know
when there was this in many cities and
states in the United States the plastic
straw debate as we might call it about
individual restaurants saying we're
going to have paper straws or we will
use a pasta noodle as a straw you know
these different things there was a
blowback which said you know those
individual decisions are fine but really
they they are almost a way not to think
about where the vast emissions come from
which is industry where is the balance
between individual choices versus
focusing on the type of activism that
will make systemic change if we think
about all the way over on the individual
side all the way over on the activism
only side where is there a balance to be
found that's most effective
well what economic power and political
power wants us to to do is to think of
ourselves as consumers
you know and say oh we can make
decisions you know we as consumers we
can change things through the things
that we buy and our power as consumers
is always weak partly because there are
some super consumers and mega consumers
we call them billionaires and they have
far more power than we do and we've got
absolutely no means of influencing them
and then there's multi-millionaires who
also have far more power than we do and
so so you know we're really weak as
consumers and our choices are really
limited anyway and generally the
difference between them is absolutely
microscopic except for issues like
whether you eat animal products or not
you know cutting out animal products
from your diet that makes a huge
difference the way you travel the way
you heat your home those are important
things most of the rest is pretty minor
consume less yeah but consume
differently you don't make that much of
a difference
but as Citizens we are powerful and
demanding new systems changes to systems
that's where our power comes in and of
course you know we're just constantly
discouraged from seeing ourselves that
way precisely because when we see
ourselves that way we become a threat to
existing power structures and when it
comes to something like the world food
system which is coming under tremendous
pressure and great threat we have to
mobilize and become active politically
if we're going to intervene effectively
in it
absolute last thing with the new
estimates that global population is
actually going to Peak and start to
decline at some point this century
does that do anything to counteract all
of the estimates that assume continued
population growth Beyond 2050 or 2070
whenever the estimate is does that
actually say Hey you know we actually
don't need to be quite as worried about
some of these things as some are
well so human population growth is about
the only environmental indicator which
is plateauing okay almost all the others
are going through the ceiling
um and it's weird how some people still
go on and on about population growth oh
it's population and that's a way really
of deflecting responsibility because we
you know living in the rich World
consuming far more than the average
global citizen we can then point to to
people much poorer than ourselves
probably brown people black people and
say they're the problem they're the
problem because they're having too many
babies it's a way of deflecting blame
and responsibility
but there is a genuine population crisis
it's a livestock population crisis
because while the human population
growth has come down to below one
percent a year yes a massive decline
livestock population is growing at 2.4
percent a year that's a massive rate of
growth and to put it in crude terms by
2050 there'll be an extra 100 million
tons of human being on the planet and an
extra 400 million tons of livestock on
the planet right they are consuming the
planet it is it is our livestock eating
habits which are driving us to Global
catastrophe above anything else so yeah
there is a population crisis but it's
not the one people are talking about
the book is Regenesis feeding the world
without devouring the planet we've been
speaking with the book's Author George
mombio really appreciate your time today
very much
thanks David great to talk to you